do you make white jokes I mean I'm not
gonna lie I've been guilty of it I don't
think it's possible to be racist towards
white people racism was invented by
white people what do you think it's more
accepted in society to make jokes about
white people because they make jokes
about the rest of us white people have
never gone through any oppression so the
question is is it okay to be racist sad
and ignorant to think that white people
have never gone through any okay can we
just like at least watch some of the
video before you start yelling this just
makes me really sad that these people
are so misinformed and brainwashed that
they think that white people have never
been oppressed trust me I know G I know
people are saying that it just nobody
should be oppressed but every one of the
one of the worst white people
oppressions was not even 100 years ago
yeah people are still alive who were
oppressed
and killed oh my not well the ones that
were killed aren't alive obviously
people I still struggle with this myself
despite their ancestral impact on
America it's not right to put all of
them in that box I don't think it's okay
to be racist towards anyone what
towards white people as well yes I don't
think you can be racist towards white
people what do you mean by that racism
was invented by white people you can't
take it out of historical context
so historically there's been One race
that has more power in the system racism
was invented by white people to protect
white power primarily what that's
[__] unbelievable that's like that
that's what they taught us in school
though isn't that crazy but if you only
have been taught that you would believe
that I know that's what we were taught I
literally had classes about that I don't
know I was taught about um American
slavery for sure and about the slave
trade absolutely but I was taught about
also taught about the Holocaust and
about Vikings who came and slaughtered
innocent people of all Races throughout
history conquerors have come and
destroyed people just to get their land
and their resources all it is is a
victimization of black people that's all
that's all this all is it's really sad
because I set caps on them because
they're not they're they're there's been
a victim ever it's been so hard so if
you're unsuccessful you don't make it
you know like there's good reasons for
it that's all it is that's all I that's
all that I see it's all Messiah possible
to be racist towards white people there
needs to be a system of Oppression
generally white people are the ones
controlling that system of impression
what he's like this is the same thing as
Biden changing the changing the meaning
of um recession oh for the longest time
it means what is it the GDP Falls below
the two quarters consecutively and now
magically that just that definition
doesn't mean anything oh you know to be
a woman you don't actually need ovaries
or to be a woman you just have to say
you're a woman they're just destroying
objective reality in real time with
everything that's all this is like I
told you convincing us that men can be
women women can be men it opens the mind
to ultimately programming
you're seeing that and all these
different things now racism is only for
white people no one else can be racist
recessions aren't real men can be women
it's just it's it's clown world that's
all this is it's all stupid I think it's
more accepted in society to make jokes
about white people because they make
jokes about the rest of us constantly so
do you feel like you have your guard up
against white people sometimes I do when
white people imagine I said that about
black people imagine I said that like
you have your guard up I have my guard
up against black people racism is
separate from a system of Oppression if
the system of depression still exists of
course it exists exists the thing is
like they hate they think like if you
you think with personal experience
you're racist so like when I'm walking
the dog and I see a black person I I
don't let I don't even let the dog get
close to the black person because every
time I have they've been like oh [__]
get that thing away for me every single
time black people don't like having the
dog so am I just gonna ignore that and
just be like oh me like no this doesn't
like this this pattern hasn't meant
anything my whole life maybe like I'll
just keep letting them run up to black
people no it's just like analyzing stuff
right I get that but that's not really
necessarily what we're talking about
with racism racism is really thinking
that some you know a person of another
race or a particular race is less than
and not capable you know what I mean or
less of a human they've just destroyed
the word racism too in saying most black
people have encountered don't like my
dog I don't know they say you're racist
say that you're racist but they don't
understand what racism really is that's
not racism that's experience I know
that's what well that's what I'm saying
that's what you're saying okay sorry I'm
telling you like when I'm at like a
business meeting or something and
everyone is successful and there's a
white and a black dude an Asian dude an
Indian dude nobody cares about the race
no one's going oh I don't want to go
talk to the black people this is all
broken [__] this is why I I don't even
enjoy watching this because it's all
this is broken this is all peasants this
is
they're not as sensitive to it as you
would be
immunity in general like white people
the privilege behind that you make white
jokes I do
a little bit but I'm trying to do better
because over the last few years it's a
growing movement where we're telling
white people not only to ignore but to
accept things that we would never say to
another race too many white people in
here and this is a space where people of
color white women if progress is the
goal that we must acknowledge
inconsistencies call out the double
standards bro you make fun of white
people all the time it's not a Whitey I
mean bro dude I'm just trying to make a
video right now but would questioning
this issue make me a white apologist or
an Uncle Tom but more importantly am I
making the problem worse by even talking
about it guess we gonna see how would
you define racism racism is judging or
seeing yourself differently from
somebody else because of the color of
your skin I would just say just
preconceived notions about someone based
on their skin color it's like a systemic
system where basically people are
starting off at a way different point
because of the color of their skin oh my
God like you don't start off any
differently because of the color of your
skin like this is such garbage if
anything you're more privileged to be
black nowadays I swear to God you are
the front of the line if I had to start
over and and be black and and work the
same that I did I would probably be
further off listen I'm going to tell you
something it was that way and it's
clapping back now and the reason is so
yes you are my privileged now because
you get put to the front of the line
with whatever your minority status is
unless you're Asian because they're
trying to hold them back along with
white people now because Asia oh yeah
Asians they haven't work yeah they're
too smart they work too hard and they
were successful so they call that they
call hard work and discipline privilege
so what happened so you've got you know
these people that are being put to the
front of the line they're getting where
they go they wanted them to be but now
the clock back and the other
consequences is that I see now I'm
looking I used to see them and think wow
they're smart they're like they're I
would think nothing of it I didn't think
about their race I just thought oh this
is an intelligent doctor airline pilot
whatever it was scientist and now I
think are they intelligent or were they
given that because of the color of their
skin and now I'm questioning their
intelligence and capability and it
really scares me and that happened
recently on a flight with a woman where
there was a female pilot and I and I
looked in the cockpit and I was like
damn I hope she got this job because
she's smart not because she's got a
vagina and someone sat in my seat and
said an extra prayer yeah you know said
an extra Hail Mary there's a white lady
had nothing to do with skin color it
just had to do with knowing that this
this quota system of affirmative action
destroys Merit indubitably so there
creating yeah so now now I am biased
I've said this where I wasn't before I
think I've said this before but like I I
have more respect if I meet a black dude
and a white dude of equal intelligence
and business capability and stuff and
like open-mindedness I have more respect
for the black dude because he escaped
the victim mindset that's been set on
him through school in his entire life
like when I meet these black people and
they're on the boats with me and stuff
and we're hanging out and they're
they're clowning all of this stuff and
all this racism [__] making fun of
it like they're they're calling this
peasant broken stuff because they
understand it's just to enslave people's
minds I have more respect for them than
the white dude that's of equality
it's not like they're overcoming racism
they're overcoming these mental blocks
that are being set on them which is just
victim mentality that's all it is do you
see what I'm saying absolutely racism is
made up social structure it exploits
People based on the race globally it
seems like there's a lot of whiteness
controlling racism is it okay to be
prejudiced towards white people though
sure is it okay to have Prejudice
towards black people I mean it's not
okay but I mean I think racism describes
a system of power so for some it seems
like racism is about punching down but
not punching up but does that mean that
as minorities we don't have the power to
discriminate let's see what the other
side would say a lot of people these
days say like Reverse Racism doesn't
exist what do you think about that
there's this belief that racism against
the person who is most likely to conduct
the racism doesn't make it racist which
is untrue if your definition of racism
is purely systematic no I don't believe
Reverse Racism can exist it's just a
matter of discrimination Reverse Racism
it's just racism I know
then yeah absolutely I had a racist
brother and he was indigenous just
because you're a minority doesn't mean
you you don't hate I talked to my
grandpa or my uncle and stuff and
growing up the whites hated the blacks
and blacks hated the whites hated each
other they were both racist towards each
other if you were a white kid walking in
their neighborhood you got the [__]
kicked out of you if you're a black kid
walking in the white neighborhood you
got the [__] kicked out right and there
were exceptions and it would be like
that's a good one
that white guy that's a good black guy
it was stupid it was
it wasn't but it it did exist so that
that proves the point that racism is and
was a thing it has gotten it got from
when he was a kid he's almost 70 years
old so you're talking about 60 50 to 60
years ago the time period he's talking
about we're in a whole different world
now and and we were even before all this
the last five six years of the racist
inflammatory [__] started so it did
exist it got shrunk to almost nothing
and then re-inflated again for the
obvious reason that when we're fighting
about [__] and they can control us
and change our lives so much that when
we wake up and we come out of the stupor
we're all going to be in Chains well
I've said this before too the funny
thing is like the Liberals are actually
the racist ones because they're the ones
saying stuff like we we can't have we
voter ID is racist because black people
aren't smart enough to figure out how to
get an ID could you even imagine falling
for that being told that you're not
smart enough to get an ID that's crazy
that's embarrassing I would just be
embarrassed like how would you ever vote
for the person that's saying that your
group of people isn't intelligent enough
to know how to get an ID and then they
go to the neighborhoods and they're like
do you guys know where to get an idea
they're like yeah you go to yeah I got
one in my wallet yeah right here you go
right up the street it's on the block of
42nd it's like they think they're idiots
it's so insulting no it isn't as well as
a woman I'm tired of the kids told that
I'm less than like give me a break up
yours I'm fine yeah you don't hate a lot
of cases of risk they don't find that
people their races are the victim of
something do you think though at times
people use that excuse of like you can't
be racist towards white people and they
mask hate with good intention I listen
to my friends who are like people of
color and they tell me their experiences
and how they feel and I just try to
that's the other thing is like once you
have this mindset that racism is a big
factor in your life and negative stuff
is is just racism then little things
that have nothing to do with your race
now the first thing that comes to your
mind is it's because you're black or
whatever like there's been plenty of
times where I'm in school and teachers
just didn't like me where I'm walking up
the street and people are just giving me
dirty looks or trying to pick fights
randomly and I'm never thinking it's
because of my skin color like there's
just crazy [__] out there
people just don't like just don't like
you sometimes it's just a part of life
but they act like white people just
don't go through that stuff at all
there's more to it than that so when I
was growing up we were taught to uh try
to part ourselves in other people's
shoes so when someone is shitty to me on
the street I don't automatically assume
it's because I'm white or I'm a woman or
something I stop and I wonder is that
person having a bad day is there
something wrong with that person maybe
that person just got a phone call that
they're that their best friends parent
died who they grew up with and they're
sad and they're twisted or they had a
fight with their girlfriend the problem
here with this is that everybody thinks
that everything is about them it ain't
all about you it ain't all about me
people are out there living going about
their business and people think that
every single interaction they have in
everything that goes on isn't me me me
me me me me me me me no nobody's
thinking about you that much that's the
[__] truth no because I didn't care
when I'm out like I don't think about
other people that much at all when I'm
at the gym I'm never looking about other
people thinking about what they're doing
I'm just looking in the mirror looking
at my own [__] so to think that people
are always looking at you is just
completely asinine it's so ego maniacal
to think that everything is about you
nobody gives a [__] I got cut off oh
that's because he hate that guy hates
women and the thing is there's been
times where I know that there's been
interactions where it's happened because
I was white but I still don't complain
about it and I still don't go and [__]
about it and go to social media I just
move on with my life because what's the
point who gives a [__] who cares like if
I was black and I actually did
experience racism I wouldn't go and
start trying to cry and complain and fix
all these races like fix the racist
people like just move on analyze the
chessboard of life and keep making the
best move making the best move isn't
going and trying to fix racist people if
you're racist they're racist let the
racists do their [__] there's not white
people going around killing black people
anymore this isn't a thing no no no not
in not in the numbers that they're
saying that they are it happens very
minimally and it sucks if it does but I
forgot what I was gonna say but you're
right yeah understand the best that I
can but today is a lot of the racism
that we see in the West in your face or
behind closed doors so in order to
address such issues policies like
affirmative action and racial quotas
were introduced in the 60s to increase
representations for historically
disadvantaged groups
has come to this nation too yes we see
today controversy remains
affirmative action harms everybody
though in different ways that's Thomas
so well put it it was a break from the
traditional justice of equal opportunity
in applying the same rules for all to a
shift towards Cosmic Justice with a
focus on equalizing prospects in
creating equality of outcome the
requirement for treating everyone the
same is very simple it's mass produced
the requirements for Cosmic Justice must
be handmade and tailored to each
individual case and so it raises the
question can both equality and Equity
even co-exist but what are your thoughts
on let's say racial quotas or diversity
hiring in the context of jobs or
university programs like affirmative
action I think are necessary and I think
they've shown to be effective at
balancing income inequality between
races job or opportunity should be given
to the person who's got the best skill I
think a lot of the time the perception
of diversity hires that these people are
unqualified where in a lot of the times
you're giving somebody the shot to show
that they are qualified if they didn't
have those quotas then less black people
would be in certain programs if they
were to get assessed they say okay no I
have 5 Asians I have 10 black people
it's not discrimination though of course
it's discrimination but it has to be
this way because that's the world we
have created I would point to things
like the Harvard Scandal we're really
really qualified Asian kids so they're
getting left out you can have a shitty
doctor because somebody got into med
school and but their scores weren't that
great but I believe in quality of
opportunity not equality of outcome I
think that's Marxist and you can only
enforce that with a gun I've also heard
instances that it actually hurts Asian
people the most who is definitely a
minority with only six percent in
America in that sense do you think
that's creating more Division I only
know what I've read and that's that they
have been effective for helping
historically underprivileged races
especially for my people for 400 plus
years we've been discriminating against
and not given opportunities I think that
there's a bit of a slippery slope that
happens when we bring people into
certain opportunities or certain
institutions simply because of their
skin color and you could even argue that
itself inherently could be a bit racist
it's reasonable to have equal amount of
different races involved in the
workplace but is it achievable the way
we're doing it right now no I don't
think it is so if achieving both is
impossible is the pursuit of inclusion
actually creating more division because
if measures are becoming more extreme
and opportunities are given solely based
on race isn't it just gonna go back to
the same equality we sought to address
diversity matters and does that include
for Asian Americans I'm not putting my
personal opinion as he was talking about
the being a white male to diversify
leadership positions so besides our
obvious history with race it made me
think why is America so obsessed with
race and racism do you think talking
about racism helps the problem or makes
the problem worse I think talking about
it with different sets of ideals
hopefully pushes the conversation
forward a little bit getting your
worldview shattered and smashed the [__]
is sometimes good white people should be
talking more about race in my social
settings with white friends it isn't
brought up enough I think there's a
certain why the [__] would you talk
about it even more when you're sitting
along with your white friends why are
you gonna go talking about racism to
black people like what this guy lives in
a social studies book
that's his brain his Consciousness is
formed by a social studies oh an opinion
book He Lives social studies GPT that's
what this guy is it's like flashbacks oh
my God awareness that needs to be used
to be raised however bringing it up in
the context of US versus them I think
that itself contributes to racism if we
keep talking about it eventually you
know it'll probably subside somewhere I
don't think it's going to go away though
I think you have to look at things hold
it can't be just one-sided left or right
I feel like there's always a middle
ground people recycle the same [__]
topics but no one's talking about love
do you think minorities blame white
people too much yes 100 they do because
it's an excuse why the [__] are we
talking about how we can connect more
and actually learn about each other you
know what the other thing is too is you
can't hold black people accountable for
anything anymore because you're called
racist so like when you see like these
kids in Chicago looting Walmarts and
[__] you can't say anything about it or
you can't even point out the fact that
it's all black people because you're
racist which is pretty crazy and like
there's kids running running in and out
of stores and the clerks can't do
anything what happened when I was 12 and
I got caught stealing a bag of cookies
the cops were called they called you was
crying in the store and what'd you tell
them I said arrest them take them to
jail take them to jail and I never stole
again I never stole again after that a
lot of these kids can use that
humiliated you after made you have
suffer some public some humiliation oh
yeah the whole family knew that I stole
I tried to steal on Christmas they got
me like wait that no wait before that so
it was so yeah the cop sent you home I'm
met you I told the cop to take you to
jail he's and he started laughing he
goes I'm not taking him to jail he goes
it is obvious that this kid does not do
this all the time cops know they gotta
feel yeah he said this he's crying I can
wait here with him but I worked like 45
minutes away or he goes I can send him
home and I said okay I'm gonna I said
send him home because I don't want to
make you stand there and wait so I met
you at the house I walked in the door
you were like to have this terrified
look on your face and we talked about it
I ended up I took you to the back to the
store and I said and I made and I said
go ahead let's get a tough guy show me
what happened I said man made you
reenact the crime so I followed Sonny he
what are you like 12. yeah made him go
to the back of the store and he picks up
a bag of Pepperidge Farm Milanos and I
thought it was just a cookie I thought
it was like one of those Deli cookies in
cellophane and it was bad it was like it
was Milanos I don't know why it was so
shocking to me at the time and so I made
you go we went up front I made you buy a
pack of Milanos and then put them back
and then give them to the girl behind
the counter and she was and she
remembered him and she's like oh he was
so said he's so cute no it's fine and I
was like he's paying for the cookies
and then we went to the police station
and we walked in and there was a cop
behind the glass and he was just opening
up his nice hot sandwich I could see the
steam coming out and I had to interrupt
him and he's like can I help you and I
said I think the guy's name was officer
Murphy I'm not sure it might be making
that up and so officer Murphy I asked
for him and he said I said I made you
ask for him and he said he I'm sorry
he's not here right now and I said well
he's got a message for him and I made
you tell the cop behind the counter to
tell officer Murphy that you were the
one who stole the cookies at the store a
couple days ago and you're very sorry
and you'll never do it again and the cop
behind the counter where the sandwich is
looking at him and he's trying to be
serious and not laugh because this
little squonny 12 year old is here
apologizing like he murdered somebody
and he's looking at me and he's looking
at me with a little bit of a smile like
right on mom so I made so I made it into
a whole experience it's so funny because
like looking back you're just teaching
me a lesson but in the moment it I was
like you genuinely think it's the most
serious thing in the world oh yeah I
made it like you murdered somebody and
then we went and uh I told the family
and at Christmas what did you get for
Christmas that year I got like like a
hundred bags of Milanos you got a lot
everyone bought a Milano cookies grandma
bought you oh grandma bought you an
orange jumpsuit a prison jumpsuit yeah
and a popsicle yeah and you got a box of
coal that's already got for Christmas
that year a lot of these little shits
could use that why is it always the
problem we talking about why not the
solution now this may sound wild but has
this obsession with race created an
environment where woke people and
racists are becoming the same thing
because if it's true perhaps one of the
first signs was seen six years ago this
small college in Washington
annual day of absence at Evergreen State
College involved minority students
leaving campus for the day to raise
awareness of their contributions but
then in 2017 organizers decided to
reverse the rules and ask why students
and faculty to leave campus instead yeah
Brett Weinstein a wiper Professor
objective citing these demands as for
segregation and discriminatory and soon
after Weinstein's objections were met
with protests and accusations of racism
a student activist called for his
resignation for promoting white
supremacy I am not interested I'm
interested only in dialectic which does
mean I listen to you and you listen to
me eventually Weinstein and his wife
resigned from their positions and filed
the lawsuit which was eventually settled
for 500k
it's not enough and so even though the
protesters may have genuinely felt that
they were advocating for inclusion
reality is is that they were promoting
exclusion based on race
frankly every every student in that
hallway has a clue like how often do you
even hear white people talking about
black people like this anymore it's so I
I never see this like I'm just being
honest
but this is so common and this has been
able to be convinced of this though I
saw this firsthand in schools where they
were just [__] on white people all
the time and look at I was just looking
at the my old school Boston Latin I was
looking at the 2023 class page like all
the kids graduating all of them have
pronouns in their bio all of them like
it's all programming like all your
consciousnesses is the sum of your
surroundings to some extent yes of
course so when they're just programming
these kids to be liberal little idiots
that's all you're creating it's just
more racist people more pronoun
[__] more depressed
imagine taking the moral High Ground
yeah and promoting division racism anger
screaming in people's faces exactly out
of all the things you could have
programmed them to be you're programming
them them to be pronoun angry liberals
when you could have promoted you could
have made them into lovely disciplined
business hard-working people kind you
could have made that like there's no
like you you analyze the chess board of
what you could have taught them and you
picked to make them angry pronoun
liberals because there all they all have
pronouns that's not a coincidence that
every single kid on this class page has
pronouns that's insane that's insane to
think about it's sad that because my
grade wasn't even emotional abuse to
make kids this angry instead of letting
them just get along with each other and
enjoy each other [__] up that's what I
was taught to just enjoy everybody I
know I know where they're going wrong
and so are we continue to head down a
path of Revenge mask as equality because
as it stands yes is it fair to
generalize an entire group based on the
actions of a few in the past sure I
actually think that's a really
interesting question because there's a
lot of research coming out about how
trauma is intergenerational so even
though you may not have experience
something if your parents did if they
ever shared that story with you you
might have that ingrained memory
somewhere I don't even believe that I
don't even believe that it's
intergenerational now if I have trauma
the way I act out like if I'm angry or
depressed will affect my children so
yeah it's not that there isn't let's say
but yeah but if your dad hit you with
shoes I'm not going to come out of the
womb being afraid when you pick up your
slippers right magically you know what I
mean and that's garbage that it's
increasing Japanese American right do
you think then like Americans should
judge the actions of my ancestors let's
say on me I think it's important that
like people have this type of dialogue
why they think a certain way why they
hold certain beliefs and that's the only
way we're going to be able to move
forward as a society okay but what if we
take a completely different approach to
it do you think it's okay to be racist
if you're equally racist to everyone
that's correct because equal opportunity
racism equal opportunity racism funny
things someone told me recently is they
want to learn more about culture so they
can be more accurate in their racism
shut up
to say it is okay to think whatever you
want it is okay if you have Hate in Your
Heart it's terrible and it's sad if
somebody is racist or hateful just
because of you know things they make up
in their own head that sucks but we are
free to do that and I am so tired of
being told that you're not even allowed
to think what you want to think you know
what another thing is too that like they
get mad at like women for like crossing
the street and stuff if they see a black
guy and it's like how can you even be
mad at the women nowadays for for doing
that like Honestly though like I know
this sounds bad but like even in my
experience there's been so many times
where like there's just like a group of
black people acting insane and like they
try to like fight me and stuff and like
I haven't done anything and this has
happened to me like multiple times I've
seen that with all Races no I know I
don't know why but it's like teenagers
acting a little nuts I don't care what
color they are I'm crossing the street
because I don't trust those mothers no I
know but like the fact that like you
can't even say this ever there's plenty
of people that feel the way I do and I'm
not saying like black people should be
be killed or like you shouldn't be
friends with black people like I'm about
to move in with the black person to
Miami because he's a g that has nothing
to do with his race you know what I mean
I don't know like the fact that you're
just supposed to you're just supposed to
ignore your own eyes it's insane but
it's not about skin color it's about
dress Behavior I was just gonna say that
too you know what I mean and there's
there's four black young black men
walking down the street and they're in
suits and they're talking and they
they're clearly high-class human beings
I'm not crossing the street but if
there's four white kids and they're
dressed like dogs and they're they're
bumping their speakers on yeah across
I'm crying no I hear you I was just I
was just about to make this point too
another thing is like it's so
interesting how the black community
holds themselves down too like if you're
black and you talk articulately you
speak like a white person and you're
clowned for that or if you do well in
school you're white and you're [__] on
for that it doesn't make any sense it's
like they're trying to hold themselves
back it's it's so interesting to see and
it's like where does this come from and
it comes from the top to keep them down
but then it's those same people that are
saying that you should vote for them to
fix them yeah it's garbage it's complete
garbage and then you have people like
Biden who are like yeah like
I'm just [__]
it's saying that we don't have the power
to discriminate as minorities using
victimhood to actually discriminate but
on the other hand is this over
correction necessary to correct the
wrongs of the past it seems like that's
exactly what Hollywood is doing whether
it be Indian Velma or black Annie a
recent trend has been replacing
originally White characters with
minorities in the name of diversity the
power of media cannot be ignored do you
think that's a good way to increase
representation amongst minorities or do
you think that's a bit lazy any time
that we to intentionally increase
visible minority representation in the
media is a good thing maybe sheep sheep
they're all sheep there's 13 of the
country is black this is just clown
World programming dudes will look at
Goku and no matter what race you are
they'll they'll say that's me they'll
look at this any guy will look at a
boxer or someone that they feel somewhat
of affinity to regardless of the skin
color they feel like that's them and
they want to just become a warrior
nobody is naturally just like looking
for someone to look like their skin
color to feel like that that's when they
need to Aspire to be like what is it
with having to make like black areas so
that women feel black women feel more
included it doesn't make any sense
here's the things that they're lying
they have this whole generation of
people that they are lying to telling
them that they are under represented
it's a it's a bold-faced lie okay in the
80s the 70s and the 80s all the TV shows
that I watched they were so there was so
much diversity I watched and show with
entire black casts all the time I
watched shows with um there were gays
they were drag people there were blacks
there were whites they were mixed they
were interracial couples on some we had
all the diversity that they say we left
it's a [__] lie and they just want
they don't show them that though they
say put on these blinders look at what
I'm telling you to look at and that's
all there is and it's all just
manipulated lies I know your own eyes
it's lies look up look up look up Good
Times The Jeffersons Sanford and Sons
The Cosby Show it goes on and on and on
we had crazy amounts of diversity crazy
is forceful diversity people trying too
hard to be inclusive and all that
honestly speaking I can't say that I
looked to Disney characters or other
characters to see what opportunities
exist for me however being able to see
other women of color in positions of
power whether it be in the legal Force
whether it be in politics was something
that did open my eyes to the
opportunities that are possible yes I'm
a black woman but when they create these
shows it's like almost so far gone for
me I don't care what my skin color is I
know who I am I think it's pandering a
lot of the time when it's just you swap
out a character you don't change the
dialogue and you say they're black now
and then you try to make yourself look
good that's that's lazy and pandering to
me it's a good point because Hollywood
genuinely care about amplifying minority
voices or is it about the woke points
don't you think it would also just be
more effective if we actually just told
real stories of minorities of like
actual people instead of just replacing
it with a traditionally white character
Matt Damon who was in The Great Wall of
China and everyone was so offended why
is it him Scarlett Johansson play like
an Asian girl oh it's like is it because
she's a better actress there's no way
there is a one Asian could have been
casted that's as with Scarlet because
Carla not all right and that's exactly
why we need to explore the intention
because besides the history of negative
racist and emasculating portrayal of
Asians of media for years films about
Asians were being replaced with white
people but in current times it's shifted
to ignoring portrayals of white people
while still continuing it also had to do
with the demographics of the audience so
if most of the country in the 50s when
those films were being created we didn't
have that many Asian people here in the
United States we just didn't so as
things shifted now the demographics of
the country has changed we have so many
more you know middle easterners and so
many more Asians and more south
Americans like we have more diverse so
we obviously we need to cater to
everybody now but at the time it was who
you're catering to that's why black
people can have black cheeses hanging in
their house if they want to like Santa
have at it who cares why are we making
such a big goddamn deal about it and
everything is so offensive you know like
yeah I actually am glad that Asian
people are playing Asian people and well
it makes the movie the film more
authentic yeah it does but you know you
got to take it into context of just the
culture of the time and what there was
and it also has to do with money well
there's also just a war it's about money
Johansson sells tickets that's it that's
all there is to it it's about money and
forget it's a [__] business
yeah based on our differences rather
than our similarities it's white CIS men
who are the least grounded most
destructive race and when media is
constantly impacting how you view
Society we're being taught that every
societal ill is the fall of white and
that as minorities we can say whatever
the hell we want about white people so
at this point what the hell even is a
solution to a more equal Society but
what I realized is that this whole time
we weren't even looking at the right
problem what do you think is a bigger
problem racial or income differences I
would say that income inequality would
be worse because I think that if we were
to be able to fix that somehow then it
could fix a lot of the other issues
income inequality I think that like we
all deserve like a certain standard of
living yes racism sucks but at the same
time it's not on the level of like
people who can't eat I think the
discrepancy of income can actually
affect certain components of race and
how certain things are viewed and so I
kind of see them as feeding into each
other racial absolutely like racial
inequality follows income inequality I
think it's still racial because at at
the end of the day that plays into the
income and everything else that goes on
like the opportunities that we have I
think it all plays into it so there's
relative poverty and there's abject
poverty in the west I don't think we
have abject poverty but people that are
down and don't want to get up and work
go bust your man very few people that
are busting their I would say most of
them are probably getting someplace it
may be slow but you're gonna get
someplace how about like let's say for
an example like LeBron James son do you
think he probably was born in a better
position than let's say like a poor
white kid in the trailer park I feel
like that's different you can't compare
the two because at the end of the day he
is a black man he still is viewed as a
black man in society having more money
would help you get along I thought she
was going to say because it's an extreme
but she went to still victimizing LeBron
James what what struggles does he face
as a black kid his dad's a billionaire
you're going to be left hundreds of
millions of dollars when he dies your
travel in circles of the but not even
that the most upper class people in the
most upper class places and you go to
the finest schools and you're still seen
as a black man and that white kid in the
trailer was tragic it is tragic he's
seen as a black man still yeah a white
kid in the trailer park still has it
better are you out of your [__] mind
kid listen this is
magic is dead it's dead yeah
all right girl good for you and he still
is viewed as a black man in society
having more money would help you get
along better and have power and still be
a victim of racism is it no matter
whichever issue is so sad
that these people are so selfish white
Liberals are the worst group of people
in the world if I'm racist to anyone
it's white liberals white liberals
they're the worst if I will never do
business with a light white I don't like
doing business with white liberals I I
just know just get stay away from me
keep your wolf [__] away from me I can't
I can't handle it the constant victim
stuff they all hate Andrew Tate it's
like they're just copy and paste NPCs
that's all all of them are you hold
square next to them and they're gonna
start [__] doing a dance move or
they're gonna give you a challenge NPCs
you know what NPC is yeah non-playable
character yeah learn that from a boy
yeah not the other what do you think
like in the news like we hear more
instances I feel like a lot of the
rhetoric in the media today is around
racial Wars it's the way rasping your
straws and dealing simply with very
complex issues but the big issue is
poverty poverty and overpopulation
people who are in charge of portraying
things in the media are often very
wealthy themselves right they don't want
to shine a light on any kind of quality
racism seems a lot more visual it's
visual yeah you've got uh that outrage
response with racism it's easy to be
like that person and when the focus is
on differences that's all we start
seeing
since 1989 Scott Adams has been best
known for his newspaper comic Dilbert as
well as his books and live streams on
social and political issues however on
February 22nd of this year it all came
crashing down this is the first
political poll that ever changed my
activities on his live stream Adams
responded to a poll that has black
respondents if it was okay to be white
and the results show that 53 said yes
while 26 percent disagreed and 21 were
not sure if you know nearly half and
more blacks are not okay with white
people oh that's a hate group and I
don't want to have anything to do you
know based on the current way things are
going the best advice I would give to
white people is to get the hell away
from black people newspapers across the
country are dropping the Dilbert comics
there's a line that gets crossed what do
you say to people who heard that and say
Scott Adams is racist are you this
prompt has several newspapers to drop
strip and is publisher to cancel his
upcoming book in a separate stream Adams
defended his remarks as Hyperbole and if
the cancellation was based on out of
context statements if you listen to it
in context makes perfect sense did I
espouse racism or did I say you should
try to get away from it he explains
facts facts he literally said that oh go
ahead go ahead let's let's no it is it
is a [__] garbage take it is a it is
adding division to division I get his
point that's the message you can't I
like I'm not saying to get away from
black people but he's saying like so
many of these black people are racist to
you and they intrinsically don't even
they they 50 in that poll then if if
that statistic is true if 50 don't think
that it's okay to be white then if you
want to stay away from racism you would
stay away from that group of people so I
get his point but then it like also it's
like you don't just stay away from all
black people so what were you gonna say
that there's that there's a better way
to approach it yeah but I don't think no
no I know he shouldn't be canceled
because I don't believe anybody I I
don't believe in cancel culture but I do
believe that the answer is we have to
change the conversation back to the
conversation I grew up with which was
unity and kindness and Reaching Across
the aisle and just just stop focusing on
race and the differences and start
focusing on the things we have in common
we're human beings we all want the same
things we want our family to be healthy
successful we want to find some
semblance of Happiness we want to
accomplish and Achieve those are the
things that we can all agree we all
share and that's where our Focus needs
to be and so saying what he said is just
throwing gas on the fire it doesn't help
it it just solves nothing well yeah I
mean I hear you like like I said though
it's like also I'm sure he's like after
that he clarified some more we only saw
five seconds right and I do like to see
things in full context to see if there's
any way that that is okay but I can
still see that there's divisiveness in
that but he didn't get canceled because
he was being divisive because
divisiveness is cool divisiveness is you
know look at I mean our president who
promised Unity does nothing but crap on
conservatives it's also like if a black
person said to stay away from white
people that would be right nothing so he
didn't get canceled because because the
reason that I am saying he's wrong he
got canceled because he said something
that you know uh was bad about black
people all of it's wrong everybody in
this situation is dead wrong they're all
jerks and we all need to come together
and again focus on the things that we
have in common focus on coming together
corporate influences are creating a
collective narrative that people are
racist and there's some amount of the
black population that's poison they're
just poisoned by The Narrative they are
victims he further clarified his points
that white Americans are demonized by
the collective forces so wherever there
are groups of people who have been
programmed by the media who have a
reflexive bad feeling about you I would
avoid them and so with further context
does he have a point every time we treat
race as the way to understand that
that's why I also don't surround myself
with white liberals because they also
hate white people right well I think if
if you meet this the problem is that he
just said stay you know you're saying
stay away from NPCs from NPCs but you
don't know that until you get to know
somebody no no pretty quick to get to
know someone they're pretty not only do
they talk about it all the time you can
look at their social medias it's really
easy to tell but he's he's going at that
with looking at skin color first and
that's what the people that say it's bad
to be white are doing and that's wrong
it's racism you're going at it first
going all right there's a black guy let
me see what's in his head no that's a
human being let me just talk to him like
the the the focus on race is the problem
whether it's the liberals or him the
focus on racism yeah but when there's
such a large percent of them that
automatically hate white people how
could you not intrinsically just think
that when you well it wasn't that large
of a percentage so 53 said no it's okay
to be white there was something like 19
or 20 20 23 sure and the rest of them so
like that's like almost half so like a
third where yeah it's bad to be white
but yeah how are you not sure people who
are brainwashed and I'm not gonna I'm
I'm not doing it I'm not becoming a
[__] racist because they tell me to
I'm just [__] not doing it chill out
chill out I'm done I'm done with these
[__] people dividing us we have to
pull it together we have to he's mad
because I'm yelling how could I not be
mad look at what they've done to this
country I I want even know you would
know more than I do I do I saw it before
it doesn't work but class does for you
if you look at class it explains
everything are we being taught through
this cycle of negative media to hate one
another and that it was always about the
money especially in America I think that
the foundation is built upon differences
and that's not right I think it's on
purpose it's perpetuated through the
media through separation through
stereotypes and yeah purposefully we're
all too mean to each other and focused
on how it's not similar when we are we
want more Unity we must prioritize
accountability because ironically it's
those who claim to be the most
open-minded that's actually the most
closed-minded and it's exactly why the
line between woke people and racists are
becoming the same thing do you think
that's the best way to achieve equality
is through hate no no absolutely not but
I think you can't have those two words
in the same sentence equality and hate
you know because if equality is
achievable it's never through hate but
instead it's about looking inwards and
having conversations to find common
ground because if we truly care about an
issue we must acknowledge the good and
also address the bad and sometimes the
ugly and that's exactly the mission to
explore the unfamiliar thanks for
watching And subscribe if you want to
see more content where I turn Street
interviews into investigative journalism
and if YouTube gets it right W can W can
again Jen Jen Jen whatever you should
have more subs yeah he's pretty new I've
talked to him before he's a good guy all
right well thank you guys so much for
watching make sure to like subscribe
follow me on Instagram I'm giving a
hundred dollars to someone who follows
me on Instagram I'm gonna announce it on
my story talk with me on Twitter let's
talk about getting this country and this
world back together back to sanity
[Music]